you know vision boards have been a part
of our lives for very long time and we
don't even know about it this is me at
18 years old in the army and you can
tell what my priorities are at 18 years
old with all the pictures on the wall
and in Arnold Schwarzenegger to the
right of me in the picture you can tell
I'm working out this was by far probably
the most popular barracks in the army
every single sergeant and officer would
come to my barracks in the morning just
to stay there for whatever reason I
always got inspected but this is a
vision board this was one of them now
this is my other vision board I had when
I was in the Army and you can tell some
of the things in their picture of my
father there's a picture of Heineken
that my favorite drink at that time you
know pictures of friends letters things
that motivated me and kept me sane while
I'm in Fort Campbell Kentucky as the
only middle-eastern in the unit and
people from Alabama and Kentucky and
Tennessee Mississippi have never met an
Iranian before and I'm having a hard
time making friends in a military that
kept me sane you know a lot of times we
think there's not a lot of value to
vision boards but but mine needs to see
things this is this this was found a
month after I bought my first Ferrari
the 458 Italia this is me at 21 years
old this was found in the middle of a
book I have not seen this picture for
years
I completely forgot about this I'm at
Santa Anita racetrack here acting as if
I'm putting the key in a Ferrari and my
girlfriend at that time has taken his
picture this was a way for me to dream
saying what if one day I Drive a red
Ferrari and then today I Drive the exact
family base if you look at four or five
eight Ferrari so do vision boards really
work is there really effectiveness to it
well one of my favorite quotes one of my
favorite quotes by Mark Twain about
vision boards is how he says you can't
depend on your eyes when your
imagination is out of focus you cannot
imagination is out of focus what does
that mean to me it means you can't
really you know depend on this thing
becoming a reality because your
vision is not clear on what you want
your life to look like so if you don't
know what your wild life is going to
look like you're not going to get what
you want when I was single and I thought
I knew what I wanted as a grad no clue
what I was looking for eventually one
day I said I'm gonna get very clear
height body toes eyes hair you know
personality energy the way she is that's
the same exact girl I found I married
her she's my wife now you can see the
picture there that is my wife
we met at she was I think 20 to 23 she
was in another relationship I was in
another relationship years later we
started dating now we're married we got
a couple kids and another one on the way
purely through visualization I
visualized this human being over and
over and over again until it was right
in front of me we got married so vision
boards why vision boards you heard what
I said with Mark Twain I like what
Will Smith once said Will Smith said in
my mind I've always been an a-list
Hollywood superstar y'all just didn't
know about it yet
think about that in my mind I've always
been an ela superstar superstar y'all
just didn't know about it yet
that's pure visualization that's pure
imagination that's pure vision board
seeing what you want in a Booma becomes
a reality right Conor McGregor the
fighter listen what he says he's
absolutely all about this he says I
always teach myself common visualization
stuff it's visualizing what's going to
happen now the key is to make it as
clear as possible to yourself so a few
things to keep in mind when you think
about vision boards is one for source of
inspiration till i'ma show you my vision
boards matter I wish you showed here in
a minute we'll go in a minute and I'll
show it to you what can we do that can
we walk around and just walk around and
do that so you can see what it looks
like on how the source of inspiration
comes from vision board as well as a
cancer reminder but to me I'm going to
be very specific on how to put a vision
board together this is not the first
time you're putting a vision board if
you are it's very simple it's easy to
make it I'm going to get it with you on
exactly how I do it specifically on
different parts now before starting a
vision board there's five things you
need to keep in mind one before you
decide what kind of a vision board you
want to make you got to think about what
you want it to represent what is this
vision we're going to represent you to
me
three different vision boards they each
represent different things you'll see
what it is but what is your vision we're
going to be representing to you what
does it mean to you to think about what
feeling you want it to give you I want
to see the vision board what do I want
to feel like emotion fire
competitiveness Drive agitation bad
memories good memories do I want it to
remind me of a thing I'm fighting for
it's my kid it's my wife it's my mom dad
where I grew up in what is it that
wanted to bring that fire to me what's a
good life whatever is a good life to you
paint a picture in your mind what's a
good life start writing and then make
that vision where be the good life that
you're willing to chase and hunt and go
after make that vision board reflect the
good life that you believe in for what
makes life worth giving everything you
got I want to feel that from the vision
board and then the last one is when
you're on your deathbed the ceiling
you're on your deathbed you're 88 years
old you're diagnosed with cancer you got
one hour to live and you're reflecting
in life what are you going to be saying
is it going to be I live my vision I did
the things that I wanted to do what was
that what was a life you want it will be
very clear with your self now so you
know it as you come into work as you get
up every morning on what you want that
life to be so with that being said I got
three types of vision words let me show
you what three types are got okay the
first one is goals like your own visuals
for life what do you want your life to
look like the second one is mind which
is philosophy on leadership and and
third one is performance like for me I
want to see the big performers and life
that inspire me
let me show you this so the first one we
have here there's three of them I get to
see this every day when I come to work
the first one we have here is great
minds and when you look at the great
minds for me I chose different
characters if you look at here Einstein
I'm a big Einstein guy where you know
his material is just inspirational to me
his quote imagination is more important
in knowledge I like sailing because it
gave me a chance to get away from people
like why does he think that way right
you mean I'm not going to live forever
so these are some of the things I like
his humor I can only imagine how I'm
Stan was if he was somebody we can hang
out with what he would talk about I have
Arnold on this side I really like how
Arnold was how disciplined he was how
clear he was he had a vision in his life
on what he wanted he wanted to go into
Hollywood politics and make it as a big
businessman hey that all of that wise it
is it luck
or did he visualize that some of my
quotes that I like the meaning of award
is its use in language if a lion could
talk we could not understand him that's
probably one of my favorite quotes of
all time then you have 300 here mother
Teresa big inspiration obviously very
big on Alexander the Great
I like philosophy so Plato Socrates I
like what Kennedy did with his life for
the most part Aristotle who worked with
Alexander big inspiration and a list
goes on you got Lincoln on this side you
got Reagan on this side you got
Washington on this side you got the
White House here discover the secret to
the world's greatest minds ever I am
curious about Minds grant was a great
leader Franklin did incredible things it
was a great inventor so this to me when
I look at this this is purely for me to
be inspired on a thinker like how do you
think what are your philosophies in life
what did these leaders do the next one
is performers I like to look at and
remind myself of great performers so if
we start down here we got Marino at that
time he had all the records Don King the
greatest promoter some people may say
why's that Don King on here no one's
been a better promoted than him Gretzky
Jackie Spitz he broke six World Records
on swimming and he won gold the one
broke the world record on each gold
medal that he won which is fascinating
you got LeBron at this time coming up
Barry Bonds at the time just crushing it
will a hundred points in a game Nolan
Ryan all-time strikeout Hank Aaron he
had the homerun record before his buddy
took it over Babe Ruth
former pitcher and incredible hitter
first guy to hit 60 home runs before
Maris hit 61 over him Schumacher I'm a
big center guy to see you Schumacher
that was inspired by Senna to want to
come and dominate Armstrong Dale
Earnhardt Shaq Jerry Rice Tiger Jordan
top earners Ray Lewis's eyes you know
this is Elvis this is me at 14 18 21
Jack Nicholson how many times he's been
nominated for a curative for his most
nomination he's got 12 nominations he's
won three of them Joe DiMaggio Ted
Williams John Wooden well Chamberlain
Vince Lombardi Rickey Henderson stolen
bases Mia Hamm Muhammad Ali and the list
goes on but this to me is topper for
I'm looking at that as top performers
and then this is me this is a
visualization what I think about some of
the cars that I like some of these may
be selfish goals this is Chairman's
office certain watch patek philippe
depending on what kind of watches you
like visionary a house in a back yard
having to put nice party and
entertaining people another home here
with a lake right up front for kids to
play at inside the house theater room
some of these things have become a
reality in my life a nice game room bar
that's you know part of my house right
now so big bathroom my bathroom is so
big right now it's insane you know we
have the travels places I want to go to
what this represents to me to learn how
to be at peace my wife and I this is the
dream Dubai which we went to Dubai and
we stayed at that seven star hotel which
this was made five years ago and I just
went there seven eight months ago so you
look at this yacht here we put one the
most incredible yacht parties in Dubai
with a bunch of our friends and had a
great time I'll show you this because
this only needs to mean a lot to you
this doesn't need to mean to anybody
else it doesn't need to have mean
somebody else may say that's arrogant
how could you put yourself II how could
you do that it's purely what it means to
you what impact you want to make in the
world so I need to be able to look at
this and just go like this by myself
and I'm fired up that fires me up
looking at this you have no idea what
this doesn't mean when I look at this it
jacks me up
it gets me emotional that's what a good
vision boards supposed to do to you
let's go back here so we can finish off
this episode so those are three types of
vision boards I believe in putting
together now things you need to remember
as as things you need to have as you're
putting your vision board together what
do you need to have first things first
pictures that matter a lot to you
friends family kids upbringing where you
grew up at maybe you want to cut your
face and put it on a nicer body because
you want to have a nice body prior
victories a time in life that was a very
difficult time in life for you because
it reminds you how you never want to go
back to that ever again something that
you put that no one knows anything else
on what it means but it's got a lot of
meaning to you what is that picture so
one you'll need a lot of pictures that
matter to you to a list of magazines
these are my favorite magazines to use
for vision boards when I did that it
took me 14 hours to put those together
and these are some of the magazines that
I suggest to use Time magazine is very
good Rob report car and driver Forbes
entrepreneur magazine Maxim's always
very creative they're fun it's a little
bit more creative on the way they use it
men's health and women's health they're
both good depending on the sexes vogue
Rolling Stone Sports Illustrated GQ s
car and whatever else you like Travel
Magazine is typically good National
Inquirer not National Inquirer what's
the other one the one that shows all
over the world with the it's yellow
Metro National Geographic National
Inquirer is terrible National Geographic
to use so that's two four magazines
three old books of philosophy and faith
depending on what philosophy and faith
you want to use for quotes sayings you
can cut out words and put them together
but quotes sayings image of places you
want to visit reminders of events that
inspire you maybe you got married in
Italy you want to put that that you got
something that happened to your life
that means a lot you want to put that on
there five get a book with athletes and
the great ones to put the sometimes you
can't find out from Sports Illustrated
but if you don't and sport means a lot
to you because it reminds you of
competition get books that have that in
there for you to put it on your vision
board
six is a three different boards
preferably like I said the dimensions I
like is 24 by 36 24 by 36 sometime is 24
by 37 but 24 by 36 you can go to a local
place and buy the frames for it you'll
need glue and then you'll need scissors
three frames go buy at a local arts and
crafts store one of those DIY places you
know do-it-yourself places and then
while you're doing your vision board
I suggest playing the right type of
music that gets you into get you into
mood you know gets you into mood to just
relax and imagine and it's like one of
these Avatar types of songs that you're
listening to I listened to a song
earlier today that just drove me insane
it was called the sounds of Earth you
know saying by this man Jordan's
George's Got Talent it was incredible it
was incredible I put it on my Facebook
page if you haven't seen it you can go
listen to it but music that gets you
going similar to moonlight sonata when I
suggest that on the ultimate
self-discovery question or something
that loosens you up or you just free
you're not tied to something so music is
very important put you in the mood if
you want to have a glass of wine even
better to loosen you up no distractions
none at all if you want to do it with
somebody else it helps to have other
people to do this with if you have other
friends or business partners or somebody
on it or spouse girlfriend husband wife
you can do that with when I say no
distractions I mean people coming in and
out you're doing business while you're
doing this middle of the day this is
typically on a Sunday away from
everybody - if you can go to a lake if
you can go somewhere else if you can go
to a quiet place where you can do that
and really be loosened up you want to do
that now
that'd be my suggestions with that now
how long will it take it all depends if
you've never done a vision board before
start with something simple and can take
you to our to make it it can take you
all the way to full day of making it and
last but not least one of the things
about vision boards is a vision board
alone I was the biggest critic with
vision boards because I was like it
really it's tough not going to work what
vision board are you out of your mind
I'm the biggest critic when it first
came down to doing vision boards until I
started paying attention on how many
them became a reality
my own life then when I understood that
I realize how much power vision boards
have in our lives when I showed that
first picture of the wall with all the
girls on the wall I ended up meeting
several of them this was attractive
this was very very strange on what
happened you know when I put up the
picture of the car when I put up the
picture it doesn't matter it has so much
power over you if you do it properly but
that by itself and you sitting home
doing nothing means nothing because if a
vision board doesn't inspire you to take
action and wake up early and get to work
it's not a good vision board it's either
it's not a good vision board or you're
just lazy a vision board needs to
inspire you but a vision board needs to
also get you to want to take action to
have those things not just be a you know
something in your imagination but
something that's willing to steer
yourself we don't want to go out there
and you know get to work and make that
become a reality so those are some of
the ways people ask how do you do your
vision board that's how I've created my
vision boards over the years and you may
have some questions on what you want to
do with your vision board but I'm always
curious to see different vision boards
that people make if you want to post it
on instagram and hashtag Patrick they
David I'll definitely take a look at
them if you got any comments about the
vision boards posted on the bottom and
if you see this video and all over the
place on youtube you know my website is
Patrick baby calm you can go to Patrick
baby calm but a lot of content but if
you are on value tamer right now and you
haven't subscribed click on that button
on the bottom to subscribe to this
channel thanks for watching
you